recommandations par exemple on a vingt
minutes
alors à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous nous battrons parce que le som
payant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aucun du monde scientifique et médicale
un peu justifié vaccinale d'abord parce
que le vaccin soit la transmission
ensuite complice ou facilité depuis cinq
mois et aujourd'hui la france représente
20 sans les contaminations qu il du
monde plus sûr st alors autant à -1% à
la population mondiale faudrait
peut-être que monsieur perron ces
fraudes quelques questions
[Applaudissements]
ce début d'année 2022
il peut pas vendre
on s'enferme dans une espèce de conte
horrible où on va soit disant apporter
des solutions mais où en fait on ne
justifie que les les erreurs précédentes
[Applaudissements]
je vous prie d'écouté
je suis muet dire qu' il ne faut pas se
passe
vaccinale
on respecte la liberté de chacun
marié mai deux jeunes sont vaccinés moi
non eh ben je choisi d'attendre
je ne pense pas être en danger du tout
pour
plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]